Another Thing Dr. Bright Is Not Allowed To
Do At The Foundation: Showing Monty Python
episodes to SCP-239 was not a wise decision.
Please never try this with any other reality-warping
SCP.
Seriously, Dr. Bright.
The Witch Child is a reality warper so powerful
we need to keep her in a comatose state to
stop her from permanently reformatting our
universe.
Do you really think it’s a good idea to
show her Flying Circus or the Holy Grail?
If we find that, by sheer coincidence, we
later need to contain an anomaly that shares
a remarkable resemblance to the Black Beast
of Argh, we know exactly who is responsible,
and we will not take this indiscretion lightly.
We might even make you sit on the comfy chair!